I think that science and faith you know
do have somewhat of an adversarial
relationship in that faith is based as
the name suggests on faith you're not
testing anything you are given the
answers in a book or by your elders and
it's about accepting those answers
whereas science is about always asking
questions it's about testing things
about assembling evidence and saying you
know do we come down on this side of the
argument of the other side and so I
think there's always going to be some
tension there now that said I think it's
possible for people to have religious
beliefs and still believe in evolution
and you know the genetic details that
we're discussing in the lectures that I
gave and the books and films and
everything else we do is part of the
Genographic project I would like people
I suppose you know if you're talking in
particular about the judeo-christian
story the story in the Bible book of
Genesis perhaps to see that as a
metaphor you know and if you see Genesis
as a metaphor the story is actually not
that different from the one we're
telling using the genetics the idea is
that we all come from a common source we
traced back to a few people living in a
particular location in the world you can
call it Philadelphia or East Africa or
the Garden of Eden wherever you want to
place it i mean the genetic evidence is
that we come out of africa that is our
scientific Garden of Eden and we
scattered to the wind you know that we
are the descendants of that small group
of people living in that at one
particular location and so you know it's
not that different from the story in
Genesis now the judeo-christian story is
not the only one and there are lots of
creation stories every group around the
world has some kind of a story that
explains its existence and you know it's
probably something inherent in human
beings that you know makes them want to
provide answers and science is one way
of answering that question faith is
another way of answering it and
traditional stories and so you know we
do sometimes come into conflict to
certain degree with traditional stories
traditional notions of creation the idea
that people have been living in the same
location forever you know that they were
created de novo out of the earth or out
of the
that live there songlines in australia
people being created at gowanus or
witchetty grubs or whatever it is and
you know you have to say that yes of
course you have this particular no
attachment to the location the
geographic location where you live and
that's very strong and you know the case
of Australia you've been here for 50
thousand years longer than Europeans
have been living in Europe but in
addition you have a deeper connection
just as everybody else does around the
world to our ancestors all the way back
in Africa and so we'd like to see the
stories that we're telling using science
as complementary to the stories that
people are taught by their elders not as
a replacement that is a complement to
the traditional notions of where people
came